say Achilles wants to run a race first
he'd have to run half the way and then
have the rest of the way and half of
that and so on but no this video isn't
about Zeno's paradox I just wanted to
point out to get to the end Achilles had
to run through every fraction of the
length at some point so here's the
question for the video does Achilles
just run from fraction to fraction if
your first instinct is like mine you
might say of course not he doesn't jump
from one spot to another
he smoothly goes along all the points
but see if he does just go along all the
fractions
he doesn't have to jump he starts at
zero but what's the closest fraction to
zero will pick any really small fraction
and there's always one that's closer
just pick the one that's half of that
then pick one that's closer by looking
at the halfway point again and again and
again to infinity this means that
there's never any distance between the
fraction our killers is on and the next
one and so he never has any jumps so it
looks like we're done Achilles can move
smoothly along all the fractions but see
how we've introduced infinity here the
total distance is just a finite number
but for Achilles to move smoothly along
it he has to go to every fraction and
there are a lot of fractions it's not
just that there is an infinite number of
fractions along this line but that
between any two fractions no matter how
tiny the distances between them there is
an infinite number more fractions that's
an insane infinity but don't worry there
is way way more when we think of writing
a fraction out in decimal it's either
some finite string of digits or
sometimes an infinite one but not all
infinite strings of numbers are
fractions of course there are all the
classic examples we'll call these
numbers irrational the ones that can't
be written as fractions but can be
written as huge strings of numbers we
said that the fractions have no gaps
right but consider this pick some
irrational number any
let's say mine starts off like this then
say Achilles runs with a constant speed
but at first he runs points seven of the
way which is a fraction so he can do
that then he runs point zero nine more
and again
that's a fraction so it's fine then
point zero zero three etc etc each bit
of this race is a fraction and so he's
allowed to run that much but he'll stop
when he reaches the end of this process
now you might be saying he never will
because there's an infinite number of
steps but don't forget he's running at a
constant speed that means the amount of
time it takes him to run all these
smaller steps is tiny so he'll get there
in a finite amount of time
in fact in slightly less time than it
would take him to run 0.8 of the way so
he gets there all right but the question
is where is there it's this irrational
number if he could only land on
fractions he would be fine throughout
this whole process since he was landing
on fractions but he gets to the end and
it's this point we didn't think existed
so does he just disappear since that
doesn't seem very reasonable we're
forced to accept that all of these
irrational numbers are there too between
the fractions even though we showed that
there is no gaps between the fractions
the fractions and the irrational are
collectively called the real numbers
because they're the ones we need for the
real world the fact that we mean real
numbers might seem obvious now but it
was a long long process in math to
invent the right numbers to support
reality this problem really puzzled
mathematicians suppose we want to know
how fast our killer's is running if we
want his average we just get the total
distance and divided by his time but say
Achilles tends to change his speed quite
a lot during the race we want to know
exactly what his speed was at a
particular point then what do we do a
better estimate is to start timeing for
a short amount of time after he's past
that point and see how far he's gone
then then find the average speed from
that
but of course that's not completely
accurate either his speed may have
changed a bit even in that smaller time
you'd want to make it even more accurate
by picking a smaller time still and
doing the same thing but of course no
matter how small the time you pick this
is never 100% accurate but we would kind
of like to know his speed at this point
in order to do physics
well then Leibniz and Newton came along
with a great idea they said why don't
you look at what happens when that time
gap is really small like basically zero
but not zero but smaller than any number
let's call it an infinitesimal then do
the same calculation with your infant
essa Mille as your time done
problem-solve now if that sounds like
magic to you then don't worry it is but
they cheerfully accepted dividing by
zero because well it worked but it
eventually started to really bother
mathematicians they didn't like these
weird and some decimals and how they
weren't zero some times that they were
later I mean it's not very rigorous and
mathematical sounding is it so they went
in sighted up heating big chunks of
maths to start making it more rigorous
in the hope that they would eventually
be able to explain calculus without the
magic their hunt led them all the way
back to the numbers themselves they
realized that what they needed was the
real numbers see this property that the
real numbers had that if a sequence is
getting closer and closer together then
it is going to converge to something
that's exactly what you need let's see
why back to our speed calculation if you
do that process of averaging each time
having the time that you use and repeat
to infinity you get a long sequence of
average times let's say something like
this then you can see that the numbers
are getting closer but since we're
dealing with the real numbers we know
that this is going towards some number
and whatever number that is define that
to be the speed of our chiles at this
point so real numbers save the day but
not without a price
we saw that even in a finite amount of
space there is an infinite number of
fractions and then an infinite number of
irrational flooded between them that is
much more infinity than you might have
imagined fitting in there but the plot
thickens
see mathematicians were very happy to
discard all those nasty and Santa smells
from maps but in the 60s a mathematician
discovered that you can reformulate all
of calculus completely rigorously using
in some decimals using that method the
dividing by zero but not really dividing
by zero thing is completely valid but
instead of getting completely rid of
real numbers to do this you actually add
in another infinite set of numbers
called the hyper reals that slot into
the gaps between the reals
but that is a story for another time the
conclusion of this video is that there
is an infinite number of numbers in the
universe what is the entire universe
infinite or does it have an inch
answering that is going to take some
astrophysics into general relativity
that sounds really interesting you
should go check out next video